um eighty percent of women choose twenty
percent of men when they're asked about
their ideal partner right so eighty
percent of women there's a pool of 20 of
men roughly right who women want okay so
80 of women are dealing with 20 of men
and that's the reason why women think
that men are trash because those 20 of
men have 80 of women to choose from so
they're going to access a lot of them
are going to exercise those options with
those 80 of women so a lot of the time
when you were saying oh the men that i
dealt with are trash you're dealing with
trash men yeah of course right okay so
when you say the majority of men are
trash you said the majority of men are
trash but it's not just my experience no
but the majority of men are good men
the majority of men are good men but you
don't you don't want that like one in
three one on three men are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year if girls wanted a guy that could be
faithful they could find one but that we
don't want them so for if we're getting
cheated on it's literally our own fault
because we picked the guys that can get
a bunch of girls
check your comments wait are you on
about like
men in the uk one but in the western
world western western worlds one in
three that
sorry they're either virgins or have it
under 30 one and three men under 30 are
either virgins or haven't had sex in the
past year so what i'm saying is like a
lot of times girls will say things like
men are trash men cheat
but literally like only five to 15 maybe
20 of men can cheat so if we're picking
the guys that cheat how can we complain
when we get cheated on you picked them
because why would we pick men just
because they don't cheat we want men who
don't cheat who have a good job you have
everything else today right but i'm
saying if you if you want to if you
wanted them you would pick them they're
right there are guys but there are guys
that have good jobs that don't cheat you
could get an engineer you get a computer
software engineer they're not they're
not known
there were 50 guys that you would pass
today didn't even notice
you know those regular guys the guys
that work at starbucks the guys that are
taking their bins out the guys that are
there's a guy in my front security desk
right
you literally walked past 50 guys today
that you did not even
care about because they didn't match
that top 20 of men that you're looking
for
so why should we have to sacrifice the
rest of what we want just because he he
doesn't he doesn't cheat why does why
does the top 20
have to cheat that doesn't make sense
just because i have everything else you
don't have to cheat
like you're asking me because i think
you're living in a fairy tale because
you you lived in a disney princess world
that's told you you can have everything
you don't get to have everything i don't
think but i'm saying i'm saying men and
women both have to compromise on things
that they want they probably want want
girls that haven't slept with a million
people but that's not really common in
the western world
so
go ahead but you also have to look
what's the age category of the men that
you're approaching because if they 30
over they should be much more mature
than being trash
i don't think age makes a difference it
does in men 100
million percent men
underdeveloped if they do not get taken
care of hundred percent every single
male is underdeveloped if they do not
get proper fathering and then they grow
up in a man's body that can kill people
and then they go out become neanderthals
and their minds are children there you
go there you go so are you saying that
um in order for a man to be a proper man
a good man he needs to be raised by a
mother and a father 100 yeah definitely
i believe the idol situation i believe
is for a man to be raised by both
parents but but but more importantly i
think one of the most important things
for a boy is to have a male father
figure in their life and
we if we're talking about this we're
talking about the subject today if you
look at the media and you look at tv
shows and you look at what is portrayed
as a father figure right in tv shows and
stuff like you look at the simpsons
you can look at family guy
right these are bumbling idiots they're
bumbling guys and it's normally them the
women in the relationship which is the
smart ones and they're like oh we know
that guys are stupid and it's like oh
i'm just gonna be a bumbling idiot and
just grab a beer and go and do
that is a that is what women and men and
young boys are being shown what a father
is and i think the masculinity when it
comes to fatherhood
has been removed from society which is
why we have such a problem with the
young males it also helps to know all
device that is available at your
disposal the negative vice if you know
all of it you can prevent your child
succumb to that vice that's important
before it becomes the degenerate it's
easy to become in contemporary society
100 years ago we didn't have much to do
it was easy to be raised by a village if
your father died your father dies now
you're selling crack
you're selling crack right now not goats
so um i want to go back to something you
said when you said um you think the
majority of men did you say bad or you
said the majority of men are something
no i said the majority of men that i had
experienced the trash but you did say
the majority of men are trash okay so so
questions yeah do you do you also feel
like the majority of women are trash
yes okay so you feel like it's equal you
just think about it are you are you
included in that category definitely not
definitely you're one of those
isn't that highly convenient right now
but that's the thing also because i'm
saying not all men are trash i've come
across a lot of really good nice guys a
lot of my friends that are male i
wouldn't put them in the category of men
are trash but they're experiences a lot
of experiences i've had my friends have
why don't you date them because they're
not physically my type it's not their
personality it's just that i have a
friendship with them right and i'm not
physically attracted to them but you
they are physically attractive just not
my type right but you see what i'm
saying like there are guys that would
treat you well in your friend zone
no no this was before so since since
i've changed
like if i came across a man that was
everything i wanted a good job like
respectful all those things 100 i'll go
for him i'm not looking for red flags
i'm too old for them like i'm literally
24 like this is that age i want to be
wifed up i don't want to be
i don't want to be with a red flag i
know you think all women will love red
flags like that's it
i don't know i don't think all women
like reflex i think women are attracted
to red flags yeah but i think that's
immaturity to be attracted to no i think
it's just honest i've got a theory on
this that i've i've worked on for a
while i think i've i can perfect it so
my
i'll just articulate as much as i can so
i i i work in the
in the nightlife industry security
industry so i'm i'm kind of privy to how
sexual dynamics works a lot of the times
and i see what i see from personal
observation
you're seeing a lot of girls a lot of
young pretty girls getting with
the dealers
the drillers
the
the fraud stars
everything that
in some so some way these kind of guys
gather for themselves in a holistic way
so what i mean by that is
these guys display a
sense of economic wealth money
number two they explain they
they exude an aura of somewhat power
these are the individual things that
young girls are attracted to all women
by that but the thing was with these
these men these men are normally getting
it very young at age but they're
displaying things that a man normally
works to
at the average age of mid-30s four weeks
and what i mean what i mean by that you
get a footballer for example um i work
in the sports industry as well so i see
this firsthand
a lot of the things that they get comes
very quickly well fame stayers
by 1820 right you could be famous
they would have a flock of women at
their disposal
but the average man doesn't attend to
the stairs until he hits his average
averagely mid-30s to 40s
so
some of these men are displaying what it
would normally take an established man
to have very younger age but what women
fail to realize that these guys are
still boys right they've not matured to
a level where they can understand
uh the power that's given to them status
wise and how to deal with women and it's
like blocking a man from a sweet shop
all his life and allowing him he's gonna
go crazy there's no boy i can i can
relate to this at a young age
when you're afforded the ability to to
be attracted to women
you don't know how to handle it at times
so women get with these type of guys and
complain
why is this happening but they don't
know a lot of these men who attain this
somewhat street fame and a financial
uh
status
they don't know that this comes short
for a man and say his early 20s to these
type of people but they're still kids so
then what type of father would that
child or that young man normally
that goes on to my point of the subject
normally these guys are fatherless
because
um from antidote and personal experience
i know guys like this you know i've
grown up with guys like this and
i see it and probably up until this day
i still see the fact that
when you're when you when there's a lack
of father when there is a lack of father
in the home
um
you don't have a good exam you don't
have any example so to speak of how to
be a man
a child looks at his father i remember
the way i used to look at my dad growing
up and he was everything i wanted to be
once you get into a certain age but his
traits rub off on you he's work ethic
he's discipline he's authority he's
masculinity he's manhood when a boy
doesn't have that at home he finds it
elsewhere right he finds it in community
he finds it in the streets because every
child is looking for a figure for every
child is looking for father in females
and males
and when men don't get at home they find
it elsewhere and unfortunately so do you
think there's a lack of
masculine
good steady
father figures right now abso absolutely
absolutely
do you think that's a do you think
that's what's portrayed or you think
that's real life it's it's portrayed and
it's real life like you gave the example
of the simpsons i grew up watching
simpsons and
i remember seeing home as funny as he
was this this wasn't my dad you know
personally and this wasn't my father
figure he was just a comedy ad but a lot
of people see this especially for the
ones who don't have dads
they see it they grow up on it although
it is comedic it is an example of how
men are portrayed in in society and when
they grow up without uh such a male
figure uh
that they can look up to
you get what you get as many of you know
i was just banned on tic tac and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible